chris hogan here i've spent a lot of
time on the road speaking with people
about their millionaire success story
whether i'm at an event talking with
someone focused on a plan or talking on
my podcast about self-made millionaire
one thing is very clear most people have
no idea what the average millionaire
looks like you're about to step into the
life of someone who crossed over to
millionaire status on their own terms
and while their net worth is in the
millions their self-worth is off the
charts it's the result of compound
discipline over time so here we go
people
it's the next episode of millionaire so
i'm glad you're here what's your net
worth one point for cool how much of
this one point four million did you
inherit nothing zero okay how much of it
did you steal from people that's an
interesting story
my name is Carrie I am 72 years old what
I learned in childhood was to be afraid
of money and a big part of my story was
getting rid of what I call the poverty
mentality you're just stuck in that
childhood pattern I'm thinking you don't
have an option I was raised on a farm in
southwestern Minnesota near a little
town called Ivanhoe
I hardly ever remember a day when I
didn't hear my dad worrying about that
we were going to lose the farm I didn't
do well in high school I was at the
bottom of my class there was a lot of
turmoil and chaos in my home but somehow
I made it to college I took out student
loans I work two jobs and I actually
flunked out the first year so I went
back to college I barely made it through
and then I taught in a little country
school in Minnesota for two years to pay
off my loans and then I went with my
girlfriend to California to teach for a
couple years and when I was there I met
a lady who had taught overseas and we
became friends and she said do you have
such a spirit of adventure you have all
received to teach so that started a very
wonderful grand adventure but a big part
of my journey about becoming wealthy and
financially solvent are my years in
Korea
I walked with a man and every night went
to Bible study with him and he was into
Dave Ramsey and investing and he said
gee you're making good money and you
ought to start investing it and I
immediately said oh no I'm a farm girl
and he said that was then and this is
now and I decided to start investing a
small amount at five mutual funds every
month
I'm really excited now to take Dave's
class starting in March the legacy
journey like they said I had to change
my attitudes that I was always going to
be that poor a little overweight farm
girl that was wanting people to love me
and accept me but you can change well I
think the wonderful class about
financial peace is an excellent tool for
people so they can get a budget and
become aware where their money goes a
lady that I'm mentoring recently took
that class and she's just on fire now
and it's just fun to you know look back
and think about that so when I mentor
people and they say no my teacher told
me I could never do this because I'm
stupid or whatever I tell them I'm an
overcomer
well the most money ever made in my
teaching career was $50,000 so I'd like
to encourage people that make that
amount of money or even less that if you
get a plan and you study Dave Ramsey's
materials and books and listen to the
tapes and his radio show which I love
that the highlight of my day that no
matter what your income is you can start
to save money and invest it but I set
out with the goal of having money as a
tool so that I can help other people and
I think you can contribute to the world
so it's mostly it's a mindset so did you
catch that hard work dedication and
following a plan these are the kind of
decisions that you can make today not
tomorrow not when it seems easier today
so if you need more inspiration more
fuel in the tank more reasons to keep
going go check out my podcasts retire
inspired because I'm all about
challenging people who want to
accomplish their dreams
[Music]
you